centuries after his death Shakespeare
remains as young caught famously said
our contemporary so which Shakespeare
play do you think most illuminates some
contemporary issue and politics or
culture my vote is Antony Cleopatra here
are two people who stand at the pinnacle
of Empires and so what does Anthony say
let Roman ty burr mill here is my place
and at the end what does she say you
take off my crown take off my robe you
know I'm no more but even a woman the
sense of really transcending the whole
world of empire and everything it
represents Rome Egypt as to humans their
love for one another I think that's such
a profound message for the world today
is anyone doing that or is that really
aspirational at the level of ruler it's
obviously a very shifting situation but
what's going on in the Middle East right
now is in a place where no one thought
this could happen and suddenly there's a
humanity that's rising up in the middle
of it it's saying let's transcend this
and be human beings who want freedom who
want love you know I think about how
especially Anthony deals with the
disappointment others have in him this
is kind of an Obama type problem Philo
and Demetrius come out at the beginning
you know this dotage of our general
offloads the measure you know we need
him to lead us in the way that he's
always led us by those rolling values or
whatever party line it is and he
realizes he's not going to do that
anymore and he has to deal with their
disappointment in him yeah and I think
that's really hard today we live in a
world in which we don't want to
disappoint our followers or our students
or political supporters and you also
have to do that if you're going to be
true well you know the tragedies are
bracketed by two by Romeo and Juliet
which ends tragically and Antony and
Cleopatra which transcendence you see
the tragedies they're all what are their
men Hamlet Othello Lear Macbeth who are
basically good men sensitive men who get
caught up in the demands of the world on
them
you see what happens so I think that
then to come to Anthony I think it's so
current I think it's so contemporary for
me it's actually titus that explains so
much about our world I feel like titus
is about what happens when a revenge
cycles been out of control you know
revenge tragedies represent something
that happens when the state is very weak
and so the Elizabethans had a very weak
state where there wasn't a standing you
know army there wasn't an effective
police force and so when something
happened it was horrible like someone
killed a member of your family had to
choose whether to rely on a very weak
state that was basically going to do
nothing or to take justice into your own
hands it strikes me that we're at the
international level where the
Elizabethans were at the national level
did because we're stepping on to a
international theatre and the way that
you described and there isn't a
centralized authority that's going to
step in and quash your revenge cycle so
if terrorists fly planes into our
buildings like what are we going to do
go hat-in-hand to the UN no we're not
going to do that we're going to engage
in vigilante justice right but we all
know how those stories at that's that's
the key thing we love revenge I mean
Americans love revenge it feels natural
and right and especially when Gerard
says it's mimetic but it's also always
belated and inadequate and that's what
people who want revenge whether it's for
the twin towers or anything else never
quite get you can never ever compensate
for the loss but that's forgotten in the
deep satisfaction we all feel when
people in Shakespeare's plays take
revenge but don't you think it's because
you want to act and in fact the thing
about losses you're so helpless so
Hamlet has to act and he finally acts
and we're happy he does maybe he's not
happy he does he does act right does
take revenge but it's unsatisfying exact
revenge exactly so we've just finished
talking about Shakespeare our
contemporary and lessons that some of
the place can teach us about both love
and revenge and contemporary society
thanks to both of the panelists for
your insights to see more of the
Shakespeare series please visit bigthink
at ww big THANK com